we are now living in an era in social
media that we have not seen since 2011
which means in 2011 you could post on a
Facebook fan page and get a lot of
people to see it and you paid nothing
for the first time since then because of
tick tock and now every company has had
to follow Tick Tock because I'm short
this point almost everybody here has
been affected by their niece going viral
on one post or a friend putting out
something about a dog getting a million
views it's giving you awareness without
having to pay for it that is the
ultimate for us salespeople could you
imagine being able to get a full page ad
in the newspaper for free could you
imagine running local commercials on
television for free can you imagine
getting radio reads by the two biggest
radio stations in your town for free
that is what social media is it requires
you to do work but what are we doing
here if we're not working